long before the birth of light there was  darkness and from that darkness came the  Dark Elves millennia ago the most  ruthless of their kind Malekith sought  to transform our universe back into one  of eternal night  such evil was possible through the power  of the ether an ancient force of  infinite destruction  [Music]  the noble armies of Asgard led by my  father King war raged a mighty war  against these creatures  yes city coming live on me  as the Nine Worlds converged above him  Malekith could at last  unleash the ether  but ask God have ripped the weapon from  his grasp  without it the Dark Elves  with a battle all but lost Malekith  sacrificed his own people in a desperate  attempt to lay waste to Asgard's army  tenure  Malekith was vanquished and the ether  was no more  also we were led to believe the ether  shall we destroy it if only we could but  its power is too great bury it deep  somewhere no one will ever find it  [Music]  you